welcome to this video playing grim Massa
Tom kissed see cozy raffia and forget
his I'm keep forgetting his name let's
see I think he allows the names oh if
i'm not mistaken how is possible i only
have one game against the sky the fields
like i have played him tons of times
weird it's really weird ok yeah the
queen bee three line very rare line in
the names oh and not particularly
dangerous but playoff for right of
course I'm playing one of the possible
antidotes and no unlike other lines hmm
sorry who unlike other lines in the
names oh um here black has scott has
gotten the bishop pair quite quite nice
for a change ok nighty for hmm
you want to play c5 really that cannot
be too great right okay night a 5-4 a
major stroke caj we know all this what
is the big point here
if I play Bishop to c6 what exactly is
your response to that yeah my dad attack
d 2 so on this was basically the only
possible response JB fine now can I just
take on c5 I think I can don't you see a
big big problem with it ok before now
okay it's not that's not ideal and he
will play if all or something here I go
to do in to be six to be seven is not
exactly great but ok it's a pawn
I wonder if he will play you for at some
point but probably not it would really
help my bishop print on b6 okay night to
deforms the smooth I think I should play
five and just just control that
okay well he's starting to muddy the
waters marwa well muddy the waters as a
normal move simply lose it okay can take
on before him I don't see anything great
against it so I'm taking it okay
ok let's two pawns and okay the only
thing is the Queen on before maybe there
is some tactical but i don't i don't
really see any tactic and the back rank
of course i have a slightly weak back
rank this is this is really the case um
night a5 okay not not spend more time I
mean he's really played a number of
strange moves but he played them quickly
maybe I should have taken with them with
them with the Queen okay as I had two
pawns rattling Queen takes I can take no
here not sure all rook rook d3 and my
back rank matic rank not really again
mm-hmm keep it simple
yeah hello I lost quite a substantial
part of my advantage that's clear when
you hope that it is still good time
warning
want to play actively trying to get
something against f2 let's rock the tool
for example or Bishop you one in case
the rook moves away from the first rank
it's not so easy if I am now to play a
move actually this should be one
especially you want to move rook takes
rook t2 ok i only have 40 seconds
ok one rock t two knocks looks valid
then threatening still rock d tomb maybe
I should have just played rugby too just
like that would have been much easier
really ok 6 i'm not sure what this is
doing actually came check
now i'm in a self pin now that's or
never good
need bishop d for bedlam jump 17 seconds
so that's the problem position is very
very good to put it mildly just winning
really
yeah yeah this guy will win the game
simply because of this idiotic time
control so in any kind of increment time
kanchan you will just lose after this
but ok what can you do check black check
for fits on time yeah yeah this is why I
simply prefer something with just one
second then people don't get away with
synonyms ok more of course I should have
cooked in much earlier this is just as
clear of course I mean rock t 2 is much
easier this wins as well but it's it
just takes to a long jack oh you don't
have I don't have the precision simply
with 30 seconds Quincy 4 is minus 7 and
so on it's um yeah I think I always kept
the gang advantage but it's it's just
it's just not a mate this is the problem
then ok it's useless to analyze it's
just it's just a total win all the way
around TM is just the porn but then he
then he started to give me even more so
it's just a matter of them of how to how
to convert it it's just the porn and a
good position I mean ba4 was not good
but he immediately and gave me a window
again after that I just I just ate up
just ate up too much time really chat
yeah long at the end I didn't I didn't I
couldn't meet him simply in 30 seconds
didn't didn't have enough time alright
thanks for watching